c'est une scène tout simplement
spectaculaire du gaz naturel qu'on brûle
comme ça dans les plaines ou dakota du
nord y en a des centaines et des
centaines de flandre comme celle là tout
près des puits lots en bons le pétrole
c'est que avec le pétrole qu'on extrait
avec le fractionnement il ya aussi du
gaz naturel qui reste à nos dakota du
nord on n'a pas les infrastructures pour
emmagasiner le gaz naturel et le vendre
par la suite sur les marchés donc on
entraîne une partie à certains endroits
jusqu'à la moitié du gaz naturel qui
ressort on le brûle le gaz naturel comme
ça c'est une méthode qu'on rejette donc
dans l'atmosphère du méthane qui est
l'un des pires gaz pour le réchauffement
la planète pour le changement climatique
y en a énormément comme ça un peu
partout le soir vous vous promenez en
voiture ces noix absolument partout et
tout à coup vous voyez ces flammes qui
m'ont donné à degert on dirait des
faisceaux lumineux des projecteurs
lumineux comme on voit dans les films
qui vont très très haut dans le ciel
dans des lumières très forte ici on se
rapprochait on pourrait peut-être lui
demander éventuellement effet moins 20
présentement mais de ce côté là un peu
plus près c'est beaucoup plus chose pour
vous et la température mais on sent
énormément chaleur qui se dégage des
plantes comme celle là